Friends, followers, subscribers,...
...we are gathered here today to bid farewell to the technology that died in 2017.
This year, we saw several Microsoft products meet their blue screen of death.
In April, Microsoft ended life support for Windows Vista.
The company also hung up on Windows Phone,...
...with an executive saying no new features were coming...
...for the Windows mobile operating system.
Groove Music faded from existence.
Subscribers of the streaming music service were encouraged to migrate to Spotify.
Apple let go of the Shuffle and Nano this year.
It seems Apple lost faith in plain old MP3 players.
But perhaps the loss that stings the most...
...is having to say goodbye forever to AOL Instant Messenger,...
..better known as AIM.
AIM defined what chat was for an entire generation...
...but many turned their back on their buddy list...
...when smartphones and social media made AIM irrelevant.